j'ai choisi de parler d'alexis colère je
sais pas si vous le connaissez c'est le
secrétaire général de l'elysée le bras
droit des modèles macron il était au
ministère des finances également alors
lui il a déjà eu des affaires de
conflits d'intérêts auparavant avec le
groupe mais c'est un groupe de transport
et msc croisières de croisiéristes il
était aussi à la présidence du port du
havre conflit d'intérêts parce qu'il
était cousin très proche d'un des grands
actionnaires du groupe msc et qu'il
aurait pantoufler avant de revenir à
l'elysée aurait utilisé son réseau bien
sûr dans l'administration pour favoriser
le transporteur et l'on apprend deuxième
affaire colère qu'il aurait également eu
un rôle dans le rachat de suez par
véolia les deux grandes l'eau les géants
de l'eau français c'était l'an dernier
les actionnaires les syndicats s'étaient
mobilisés parce que il y avait aucune
raison que veolia mange suez si ce n'est
de détruire davantage d'emplois et de
faire qu'on n'aura pas forcément un
champion français même si veolia bon je
suis est d'augmenter les marges
peut-être augmenter les marges bien sûr
et avoir de nouveaux marchés publics et
comme la régie de l'eau de paris et
d'autres or on apprend que le parquet
national financier ouvre une enquête et
ça pourrait être la faire de trop
peut-être pour alexis colère alors qu'on
rentre en campagne présidentielle est ce
qu'ils monnayent mac on peut le garder à
l'elysée il était également
dans le halo de la cellule riposte lors
de la sphère benalla on le voit c'est un
peu le factotum des modèles macron il
est là pour tout faire mais quand il ya
trop d'affaires eh bien peut-être que
jupiter va devoir se séparer de son
faire valoir
[Musique]